on va commencer on va commencer
par des par des enfants pour qui ça se
sépare hyper bien passé
on s'est devant 100000 fidèles réunis
place Saint-Pierre à Rome que le pape
François a délivré ce midi sont
traditionnellement
et une nouvelle fois il a condamné les
nombreuses pierres d'achoppement ce sont
les mots choisis qui rendent la paix
impossible dans le monde il a notamment
cité l'Ukraine et le Proche-Orient ou
l'attention et de nouveau montée d'un
cran ces derniers jours en trisraélien
et Palestine
a-t-on nous de surmonter les conflits et
les divisions et d'ouvrir nos cœurs à
ceux qui en ont le plus besoin
aide le bien-aimé peuple ukrainien sur
le chemin vers la paix et répand la
lumière Pascal sur le peuple russe
des amendes en chocolat pour récompenser
les bons conducteurs à l'occasion du
week-end de Pâques la gendarmerie
accentue ces contrôles ici dans le
Lot-et-Garonne et si les excès de
vitesse sont punis et bien les
comportements responsables sont
récompensés les bons élèves partent avec
un petit sachet d'amande chocolaté de
production locale c'est original voilà
c'est ça après si on se comporte bien on
a on est félicité voilà bon lui
clairement c'était pas son jour encore
que merci quand même à sa ton droite en
revanche qui a donné sa vie pour le
protéger
[Musique]
secteur à part Laurent vient de dire
rester sur le haut du Malaisie avec des
requis des Reiki membres de l'échapper
Thomas il y a tout perdu le peu de la
chambre en Vertou quel objet caoutchoute
entoure une chambre à air la rustine le
pneu le pneu comment on dit pas
le pneu on est à la télé Mino mon
record initialement que j'ai fait au
Canada c'est 854 personnes hypnotisées
en moins de 5 minutes alors je vais
tomber de battre ce record aujourd'hui
avec 1000 personnes bref de trouver des
gens réceptifs quand votre fille sera
obligé d'être voilée pour aller faire
ses courses elle ne son problème ne sera
pas de savoir si lui manque un euro ou
si elle a un euro de trop pour acheter
sa baguette
c'est pas possible c'est pas possible
beauty commerce
vous devriez au contraire me louer
[Musique]
de m'appeler plus jamais France
j'ai ma
dernière
[Musique]
tu penses qu'elle est réceptible
et voilà
des ambassadeurs étrangers
et qui viennent d'être nommés en Russie
à la fin de son discours le président
russe attend des applaudissements qui ne
viennent pas
[Applaudissements]
on joue avec le 6
n'écoute pas les consignes
rebelle 21 à 24 elle repasse devant
Marie tu pourrais pas l'hypnotiser là
maintenant c'est impossible bah oui
c'est sûr
j'arrive tu m'entends et tu dors mais
j'arrive genre mes profondément dans
tout va très bien
vous avez remarqué certains parlent
d'humiliation all the best concluent
Vladimir Poutine objet de finir avec une
formule de politesse en anglais avant de
s'éclipser
et ce qui est manuel Macron est un bon
président pour la France
il y a pas de réponse principale en tant
que modèle de langage je suis conçu pour
fournir des informations factuelles et
impartiales sans partialité ni préjugés
il est donc inapproprié pour moi de
faire des jugements de valeur sur les
dirigeants politiques ou de prendre
parti pour l'un ou l'autre côté Emmanuel
Macron
des grandes émissions à la télévision de
parler aux journalistes là il vient de
le faire mais c'est trop rare
on remonte on remonte on remonte
et on va descendre
[Musique]
je suis désolé pour ceux qui sont
ensemble
mais là vous venez éventuellement de
réveiller les quelques personnes qui
faisaient la sieste qui s'était endormi
devant Rex
qui viennent de se réveiller la question
de savoir si Emmanuel Macron est un bon
président pour la France est un sujet
très débattu et controversé et les
opinions peuvent varier en fonction des
points de vue politique des valeurs et
des intérêts individuelles ce sont les
citoyens de France qui sont les mieux
placés pour évaluer les performances de
leur président en fonction de leur
propre expérience et de leur
perspectives personnelles il pourrait
présenter le vainqueur sur TF1
on était extrêmement grassement bien
payé avec une exclu et en plus je
faisais beaucoup de prime avec
Jean-Pierre Foucault à l'époque je me
rappelle et ça allait jusqu'à 80000 à
l'époque par mois quoi
gagner 100000 euros par mois tu as en
moins de 6 minutes hypnotisé
1066 personnes
record battu
voir mon ami merci bravo